j'ai comme glanage de l'année s'est
ramassé après la moisson en 2000 la
cinéaste agnès varda consacre un
documentaire au glaneurs sur le marché
du boulevard edgar quinet à paris elle
rencontre alain fonteneau qui ramassent
des fruits et légumes cet habitant de la
verrière et vient régulièrement glaner
de la nourriture avant de rentrer dans
sa résidence donner des cours
d'alphabétisation
la documentariste est séduite par le
personnage elle l'intègre à son projet
aujourd'hui alain fonteneau vit toujours
au même endroit
c'était à la fin du marché et elle m'a
posé la question vous êtes à un grand
mangeur de persil
je dis oui parce que perçu c'est très
bon pour la santé
et c'est à partir de ce moment là
qu'elle m'a posé la question s'il était
d'accord pour être filmé deux ans après
agnès varda le retrouve pour une suite
des clameurs et la glaneuse alain je le
rencontre souvent depuis deux ans le
samedi je vais à la fin du marché et on
va prendre un café quand il a fini de
remplir son gros cinq cinémas
on va dire vous savez c'est quand même
un van gogh
si vous voyez un van gogh un tabou eh
bien je me savais que tu n'es pas de
gauche si vous voyez un film d'agnès
varda
vous savez que c'est du agnès varda
c'est disons que là il ya une marque
voilà on voit un film agnès varda on
sait que celles fixées agnès varda sens
alors que qu'au départ on nous avait pas
dit que c'était
c'est alain fonteneau n'a pas changé
depuis les années 2000
il donne toujours des cours de français
aux habitants de la verrière en 2016
il sort son autobiographie c'est le
livre que j'ai écrit et une erreur pis
itinéraire bis retrace sa vie son
enfance à la campagne son travail
d'enseignant en biologie puis son
nouveau départ à paris où il rencontre
agnès varda laisse voir la cia police au
documentaire il repasse ce livre parce
que quinze ans après quelqu'un m'a fait
remarquer qu'il serait intéressant que
j'écrive une autobiographie de ma vie
moi je veux dit bon bah ma vie n'a rien
d'extraordinaire et elle m'a dit tout si
les mêmes ici une vie banale elle est
forcément original la dernière fois
qu'elle a un fondement croiser la
réalisatrice et en 2016 pour lui offrir
son livre de cette grande dame du cinéma
il retient sa simplicité et sa voix
posée